[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
May 24th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
families with life insurance policies
have been denied death benefits that
they paid for because of paperwork
errors made by their employers Wall
Street Journal reporter Leslie cism
joins us to explain how it happened so
Leslie what type of life insurance
policies are involved here we're talking
group life insurance that is provided by
employers as a benefit there's usually a
basic amount of life insurance a form of
term life insurance it's usually one or
two times the employee's salary
then the employer makes available what's
called supplemental life insurance which
is an amount of insurance above the
basic amount typically employees pay for
summer all of this supplemental life
insurance and some of it may require
going through a qualification process
and so what happened that caused so many
families to be denied coverage that they
had paid for some employers dropped the
ball and did not provide the health form
for their employees to fill out for this
supplemental amount of coverage but the
employers tally up how much premium they
owe the insurance company from these
workers the employers went ahead and put
down these workers as paying for their
supplemental insurance though the
insurance companies were never provided
the forms for these people so the
insurance companies had never approved
it however there is no system of talking
between these employers and the
insurance companies as to which specific
employees had filled out these forms the
insurance companies were receiving
aggregated premium you know a lump sum a
premium from all of the workers who were
paying for their insurance but there
wasn't a system for them to distinguish
which people had been properly approved
for their insurance now in your
reporting you say that several insurance
companies are under investigation but
last month the labor department reached
a settlement with Prudential Financial
what is Prudential accused of doing the
labor department says it determined that
Prudential had denied more than 200
death benefit claims in recent years
totaling as much as seven million
dollars in instances where people had
been paying for their insurance the
employer had been deducting the premium
amounts from their paychecks and
forwarding that amount to the insurance
company but Prudential had never
verified that all these people have been
approved for their life insurance so
when the death claims came in Prudential
looked in its files and said we never
approved these people for their life
insurance for their supplemental life
insurance so we have to deny the claim
this required an application and our
approval and this is something we never
gave so the fault lay with the employer
for not having gotten the form to the
employee and getting it filled out and
submitted to the insurance company for
its approval but the labor department
said listen if you're an insurance
company and you are collecting premium
you got to have a better system in place
for talking with these employers and
figuring out exactly who has been
approved and who's not and you should
not be accepting premium if you haven't
approved these people did Prudential say
if it intends to change its procedure in
any way Prudential signed an agreement
agreement with the labor department
under which
agreed to do a better job of what it
already is doing which is telling
employers that they must handle this
Duty properly and it will reinforce that
if the employers don't handle this
properly the employer will be liable for
paying out the death benefit to those
people Prudential also voluntarily
agreed to go back several years review
the denials and if the denials were
based solely on the lack of this
original Health form that it would pay
the death benefits in summer all of
those instances what can people do who
have life insurance policies with any
company to avoid getting caught in a
situation like that so one thing people
can do is re
materials and if in fact it says you
need to fill out a form you do
unfortunately need to be looking at this
material when you make a purchase and
you need to go to your HR department and
say hey this thing says I'm supposed to
fill out a form you haven't given me a
form what's up with this
insurance companies send out approval
letters or have other communication
digital communication once the employee
is approved but someone who didn't send
in the form wouldn't get such a
notification so they don't seem to be
aware that this was required and thus
they end up in these bad situations that
involve a lot of heartache and grief and
perhaps serious financial hardship at
the point their beloved one has died did
people get any money back during this
process according to the lawsuits and
the labor department
in some or most ins or all instances the
people were refunded the premiums they
had paid when the insurance company got
the death claim looked in its files and
said we don't have a health form for
these people we don't have the
application from these people it
promptly
reimbursed all the premiums but the
problem is at that point families were
can counting on this death claim to help
their family in the event of a death so
to get your premium back that's the only
right thing the insurance companies
could do they had to do that but you
know like in one instance I think the
labor department said a family got back
eight thousand dollars in premium from
years and years of payment whereas they
were counting on some large death
benefit so to get back eight thousand
dollars in premium is nice but is not
going to make up for that missing death
benefit but the insurance companies were
denying the benefits on the employer's
mistakes so these people or just have a
bad taste in their mouth and some of
them had sued the insurance companies in
federal court and that's partly how the
labor department knew the problem
existed these lawsuits were
proliferating that's Wall Street Journal
reporter Leslie cism and that's your
money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the
Wall Street Journal
[Music]